direction le château de la branchoire à
Chambray-lès-Tours un incendie s'est
déclaré hier soir dans les combles de
l'édifice une très mauvaise nouvelle
pour la municipalité qui avait engagé de
gros travaux de rénovation depuis un an
on fait le point sur l'ampleur des
dégâts avec Faustine une
les dégâts sont bien visibles au
lendemain de l'incendie une grande
partie de la toiture de l'aile centrale
du château de la branchoire est parti en
fumée les pompiers étaient encore sur
place aujourd'hui même si le feu a été
maîtrisé hier dans la soirée sans faire
de victimes là ce matin nous sommes
toujours en face de déblais surveillance
pour rechercher les derniers points
chauds dans les cloisons par exemple et
être certain de d'avoir fait le tour du
feu complètement ce sont des témoins qui
ont alerté les secours aux alentours de
19h40 car des flammes dépassaient du
toit du château dans les lotissements
voisins certains riverains aussi ont
aperçu et senti les fumé ça nous a
inquiété parce que c'était pas loin on a
senti un peu l'odeur
du feu on a ouvert les volets et là on a
vu qu'il y avait plein de pompiers il y
avait du monde qui bougeait on essaye
d'éteindre le feu et vers 22h je pense
22h30 tout était fini le château était
en cours de rénovation depuis un an afin
d'y créer des salles d'événements ciel 5
millions d'euros de travaux qui devaient
se terminer l'été prochain on avait
réalisé les deux tiers de travaux le
plus gros était fait tout ce qui était
gros œuvre était fait en été en train de
s'engager dans les travaux de finition
c'est-à-dire de peinture de décoration
intérieure donc malheureusement tout ça
aujourd'hui et compromis le Gardon
espoir bien entendu de reprendre des
travaux
dans un délai que je ne peux pas dire
sera peut-être un an sera peut-être deux
ans pour les mener à leur terme
l'histoire n'est donc pas encore
terminée en attendant une enquête est en
cours pour déterminer les causes de
l'incendie